So, now that I'm in quarantine,
I have basically this one hobby,
which is going for walks.
I do everything on walks,
I listen to podcasts, I take meetings.
There's just one thing
that's really hard to do on a walk
and that's reading a research paper.
Or so I thought until I learned about
a new project that my colleague, Kaz Sato,
who's based in Japan, is working on.
He used machine learning
to transform PDFs into audiobooks.
Today, I'll show you
how to do the same thing,
how to use computer vision
and text-to-speech
to turn your own PDFs into audiobooks.
Let's get started.
♪ [music] ♪
So first I decided to chat with Kaz
to see how he built his project.
I have converted the PDF books
into the text file
by using the Vision API OCR feature.
I have used here Auto ML Tables
to understand the layout of the document.
And then I have used
the Text-to-Speech API for converting
the pre-processed text
into the .mp3 audio file.
I wanted to build
my own version of Kaz's project
that would convert
research papers into audiobooks.
So I'm going to copy most
of Kaz's architecture.
First, like Kaz, I'll create
a Google Cloud Storage bucket
where all the PDFs
I want to be converted will be stored.
Next, I'll use the Vision API
to extract text from those PDFs,
which I'll later convert
into spoken words.
I'll use Kaz's code which calls
the Vision API from Python.
Here's what the output looks like
when you pass a PDF through the API.
As you can see, it contains
both the raw text
but also the X, Y coordinates
of the characters.
So Kaz set up this project
in a really nice way.
He used a Cloud Function, which is a way
of running a tiny bit of code
in the cloud when something happens.
In our case, we'll set it up so that
uploading a PDF to cloud storage
triggers the cloud function that kicks off
our audiobook-making pipeline.
I'm going to create a cloud function, too,
and copy Kaz's code into it.
After we've converted the PDFs into text,
we still need to decide
which parts of the PDF text we want
to include in the audiobook.
For example, we probably want
the body text and the title,
but we probably don't care about
things like page numbers
or references or image captions.
So this is where our custom
machine-learning model comes in
to do what Kaz calls
remove the garbage text.
The Auto ML Tables model
can detect whether
a text could be a garbage text,
such as the page headers
or the page numbers,
or the body text, or the other small labels
you can find in the diagrams.
So to handle the problem
of identifying the garbage text,
Kaz built a custom machine-learning model
using a tool called Auto ML Tables.
To train that model,
he collected all this information
about the size of the text
on the page and its position.
But in order to do that, Kaz had
to manually label a lot of PDFs,
marking the good text
from the garbage text.
It took three hours for each book,
and for the initial five books,
it took like two days.
That's 15 hours. (laughs)
I could do that because I was back
in my parent's home,
and I had nothing to do
except for this one.
So in order to avoid
labeling data myself,
I'm going to use a little cheat here.
Instead of building a custom model,
I'll just look at all the font sizes
and whatever font size
is most frequently used,
I'm just going to assume
that's the body text
and that should go into the audiobook.
If you want more details
about my and Kaz's approach,
make sure you check out
the blog post linked below.
And now for the fun part:
generating computer voices!
(computer voice 1) I'll take it from here.
Google Cloud Text-to-Speech supports
over 220 voices in 40+ languages.
Let's try another one.
(computer voice 2) I am your narrator.
(computer voice 3) I am your narrator.
(computer voice 4) I am your narrator.
(computer voice 5) I am your narrator.
(computer voice 6) I am your narrator.
Perfect. Now that I've chosen
my favorite voice,
I can update the codes,
that when I upload a PDF, an audiobook
will automatically be generated.
Let's take a look at what it sounds like.
(computer voice 1) A promising path
towards autoformalization
in general artificial intelligence.
(computer voice 2) Christian Szegedy.
Today, AI systems are able
to learn solving tasks
that used to be thought of taking
uniquely human capabilities,
until recently.
(Dale) Thanks for watching.
Let me know in the comments
what you want to see me build.
See you next time.